there is a very interesting new poll out
a 2024 poll in which joe biden is
leading donald trump by six now why do
we care about that it's september of
2022. well there are a number of
different reasons one is that like no
election i can remember
we are already sort of in the 2024
election and usually each election is a
very kind of compartmentalized with very
clear boundaries election and in this
case it is very different as much of
what is already happening now uh bears
directly on 2024. it's also something we
care about because donald trump's
refrain has been i'm winning every poll
now
we don't know if trump is running we
don't know if joe biden is running so
what it would even mean to lead a poll
is a question but it is not true that
donald trump is leading every poll let's
take a look uh the hill reporting new
poll shows biden with six point lead on
trump
biden is leading trump by six in a
hypothetical 2024 presidential match-up
new polling shows in a yahoo news yougov
poll released yesterday wednesday
48 percent of registered voters said
they'd vote biden if the election were
today and 42 say they'd vote trump now
that's only 90 of the electorate meaning
there's still another 10 percent in flux
that is often the case in these polls
biden held a three-point lead in the
hypothetical 2020 rematch in august
from august to september biden's lead
has gone from three to six
now again
a bunch of different caveats first of
all this is just one poll
if we look at more polls you'll see that
trump is leading some of them but more
recently biden's leading all of them if
you look at an emerson poll from about
two weeks ago it's biden plus one
if you look at a wall street journal
poll from about two and a half weeks ago
it's biden plus six and then before that
you had trump leading three polls in a
row one of which was an admittedly
right-leaning trafalgar group poll
so it is not the only poll this new poll
in which joe biden is leading but what i
want to focus on is the absurdity of
what is going on in the united states
trump belongs in prison more than he
belongs on presidential polls the idea
that trump might even have a shot at the
republican nomination
is
extraordinarily disturbing
and embarrassing for the country
this is a guy who should never be
running again for anything he shouldn't
be allowed to run again based on the
things that he that he's done
and instead he's
in it in a hypothetical matchup for the
presidency
and it says way more about the voters
than it does about donald trump himself
and so as i always say
it's time to start getting your friends
your family and your community
um aware of the fact that they must vote
and what better way to warm up to voting
in 2024 than voting in 2022 as i said
before because the concern of course is
and this is why i started this segment
by saying in a way that isn't typical
this election in 2024 are kind of
running together
the 2024 election
is going to be greatly influenced by
what happens now in more ways than one
yes
if there is a big mag at
uh running of the table in november
that emboldens trump for 2024 and it
does build the strength of the maga
movement for 2024. so maga people are on
the ballot if they lose it's bad for
trump if they win it's good for trump in
2024 but there's a much more disgusting
way in which the november election bears
directly on 24 which is there are people
who might win in november
who will help trump steal the election
in 2024 at the top of the list of course
is republican gubernatorial nominee for
pennsylvania doug mastriano mastriano as
i've told you before and i know many of
you have already heard this masteriano
was at the january 6th riot
and masteriano
is a big lie proponent
and if indeed masteriano is the governor
in november of 2024 and the democratic
nominee wins pennsylvania by a few
points mastriano
will
try to steal pennsylvania for the
republican candidate he will try
and i rarely make predictions because
there's so much left to
circumstance and possibility and
probability
masteriano will try to steal
pennsylvania's electors in 2024 for the
republican if it's a republican that you
know he's in league with like trump and
that's why this is such an important
midterm election trump stole
nuclear documents classified documents
top secret documents to do who the hell
knows what with
and he's polling in the 40s he's polling
in the 40s
among registered voters in the united
states humiliating
and the world sees it
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 percent made from bamboo a
bamboo stock keeps growing it can be
harvested forever it means that the soil
and the ecosystem aren't disrupted no
carbon removing trees are cut down the
paper industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one american uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
soft toilet paper real paper loves the
david pakman show they're giving my
audience thirty percent off your first
order and free shipping when you go to
real paper dot com slash pacman and use
the code pacman at checkout the link is
down below